في ضيافتنا اليوم نجم عالمي تخطط مسيرته
الفنيه اكثر من عقدين من الزمن انه عازف
الجهاز العالمي كمال مسلم معزوفات تحمل
هويه خاصه بهذه بها حيث دائما ما يحاول ان
يترجم احاسيسه ومشاعره ليلامس بها قلوب
الناس بالفعل يقدم مسلم مشاهدينا خليطا من
الموسيقى الشرقيه ممتزجه مع الموسيقى
الغربيه واللاتينيه تحديدا وحتى الاسيويه
مع رشاقه تجعلها متداخله بطريقه جذابه
كمال مسلم احد ابرز موسيقيه المنطقه
والعالم في الجهاز ويمتلك تفردا في عالم
الموسيقى
له تصريح سابق ربما اصبحنا نستشعر كثيرا
هذه الايام حيث يقول الموسيقى العربيه
الحديثه فاست فود دلاله على عدم قدرتها
على الصمود
[موسيقى]
بنرحب الى مشاهدينا في الاستوديو
بالموسيقي كمال مسلم اهلا بك كمال معنا
المصطلح وعنجد انه دقيق بالفعل مش كل
الاغاني بس
الفكره انه موسيقى غير مستدامه يعني ما
الها
عمر طويل
مصنوعه بطريقه سريعه مش مفكر فيها بعمق
الاحساس فيها الداخلي المجتمع من عمق خلاق
كريتف سوس يعني هي معتمده على
تكنولوجيا الموجوده اليوم في صناعه
الموسيقى اليوم الميزيكشن كتير اسهل من
قبل 30 سنه يعني عنا
مكتبات موسيقيه بتختار منها انت اجزاء
وبتركبها مع بعض يطلع معك لحن او بيطلع
معك ايقاع لازم نجيب كل عازف عشان يعزف كل
مقطع وكل جزء لايف بالاستوديو انت عندك لا
بكره رايحين على الذكاء الصناعي الاصطناعي
ممكن يغير لكن لكن اليوم خليني اول شيء
ليش
انا ساكن في دبي ليش في حفله شيرين
[موسيقى]
كصحفيه
جميله وكانت جميله معي في الجامعه لمدرسنا
هندسه معماري احنا كنا في هندسه معماري
انا ضليت وهي حولت صحافه
كويسه تحياتي لكل من يعرف هذه الانسانه
ووقفه طبعا في حقها دائما احنا نقول رحمه
الله عليها اليوم
جميل جدا عشان تكريم الناس عن طريق
الموسيقى وتكريم ناس ذو قيمه
وعندهم باع طويل بالعطاء مثل شيرين ابو
عاقله الله يرحمها في مجال الصحافه وصوتها
كان صوت الحقيقه
خلينا نفهم اكثر كيف او نسمع خلينا بدايه
قبل ما تشرح لنا كيف هذا الفيوجن ما بين
الجاز الغربي مع الموسيقى الشرقيه كيف
بيتزاوجوا مع بعضهم الحقيقه في بين
الموسيقى العربيه والجاز بالذات نقاط
تلاقي لانه تعتمد على الارتجال
كلاسيكيه يعني تعتمد على الرجال او على
الموال يعني هو في الاصل
خلينا نسمع اكثر يلا خلي يعني مثلا احنا
بنعزف على مقام الرست مثلا
[موسيقى]
نفس هذا المقام ممكن اعزفه انا بلوز
هذه ينطبق على اكله بس على الجهاز ولا على
اكثر من
شغلي بالفيوجن اللي بعمله دخلت الجهاز
دخلت موسيقى من اسيا عناصر موسيقى هنديه
مثلا نوعا ما زي مثلا انا بعمل انا
مقام هندي مثلا اوكي بس هذا على السيتار
يختلف
يعني
نظريات الموسيقى بدنا نسمع اشي حلو
مشاهدينا يعتبر
[ضحك]
[موسيقى]
الله نقدر نقول بانه اليوم الموسيقى لا
هويه لها او لانتماء جغرافي لها من الممكن
ان تحاكي كل البلدان ممكن ممكن يعني دخلنا
بعالم بالعولمه وهيك بس انا بحاول دائما
في موسيقتي انها توصل للكل مع حمل هويات
معينه واضحه واضحه الواضحه احنا بدنا ننه
ي حلوه ضلنا 30 ثانيه احنا طماعين
على صباح العرب جميل مقاليد الهواء كلها
لك اوكي احنا نعمل شي مرشح بسيطه
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات